in 2004 when noodle bar open to lukewarm
reviews we decided to go for broke we
stopped serving the ramen bar standards
and started clicking whatever we felt
like it was a creative atmosphere with
are no bad ideas I was facing
foreclosure I nothing to lose the bank
wanted everything total failure or
complete turnaround were the only
options luckily it was a ladder after
mowing through open we try to bring that
go-for-broke mentality to everything we
do every dish concept and new venture
taking risks lead to good new food food
so good no one is talking at the table
that's what I see at our restaurants
that's what my chef see and we want it
to be completely silent
even though musics playing that's the
best noise a chef can hear when the
customers not just satisfied but their
static dazed and confused by what
they've just tasted you don't want
people to talk it's not good enough
after they've eaten something you want
them to be like oh my god what the
just happened those types of dishes
don't come easily they often have to be
built up and torn down dozens and dozens
of times and even when there's a chance
they won't connect with audience but
with that connection between the chef
and the diner gives the restaurant their
vitality you know it's this sort of this
trust this give-and-take in over ten
years I've learned what it means to be a
business owner and a boss so now I place
high value on systems accountability in
organization so we can sort of get that
moment more and more every day my cooks
and chefs have to balance contradictory
ideas the anarchy that makes the best
dishes in the order that makes the best
business it's a paradox that we'll never
be able to easily understand or execute
because there's a push and pull between
order and creativity it's like I'm
mandating that we capture lightning in a
bottle and then carefully label and
store that bottle on the shelf it's
asking them possible as a chef you're
used to being asked to do the impossible
you're constantly striving to be the
best
the desire sometimes men if that's
itself as a kitchen full of yelling I
can tell you personally that kind of
kitchen space is where you know nobody
wants to say anything there's just this
to scare any kind of creative process
reaches a standstill for a dish to grow
you need feedback if there's one to
toilet Aryan opinion in the kitchen
creativity withers on the other side of
the spectrum you can have a
free-thinking kitchen environment sort
of like this hippie free-love stuff a
kitchen where all ideas are good ideas
and every dish is executed this
feel-good zone is equally quiet because
cooks are afraid to express criticism
constructive criticism is a crucial
ingredient in any good dish there's
dishes where people just don't know what
to say great dishes need to run a
gauntlet for ideas that is both tough
and fair I used to go back and forth
about whether I needed to be more
militant or more relaxed but I've
realized our restaurants work best when
they're both simultaneously an
environment where cooks have thick skin
and a high level of empathy being in
that zone that fleeting moment where
everything is in balance is rare in that
moment food becomes more delicious it
could be a 10 or 20 course degustation
or a fish taco that zone is when you're
delighting customers
it's like balancing a tipping chair we
have had periods of too much doubt when
we were constantly over correcting and
failing to hit that mark if there wasn't
enough efficiency and structure we'd
bring in a sous chef an enforcer a
hard-ass a drill sergeant someone that
came from an old-school French punch you
in the face kind of kitchen and those
kitchens really did exist not so much
these days if there's too much structure
in order we'd bring in somebody that
just came back from cooking abroad from
a magical place like Luger eats in San
Sebastian fat duck in England and Bray
or elbow Yi in Rosa Spain with their
mind full of new ideas and their heads
in the clouds in the golden early day as
a noodle bar it was just me and a few
cooks and once we ditch the gyoza and
the edamame we started serving dishes
with the techniques I learned at various
New York top restaurants
and cooking abroad in Japan we created
refined food with extraordinary
ingredients that wouldn't normally be
found in a restaurant in our price range
I just believe good food food should be
for everybody I got tired of cooking
food on the Upper East Side for really
rich people and if you travel abroad
you'll see that good food is for really
everybody and cheaply and you know we
temporarily found that sweet spot
between polished and uninhibited we
honed in on a particular kind of
deliciousness that arose from that
conflict of my highbrow and lowbrow
tastes just because cooks make fancy
food at fancy restaurants doesn't mean
that's what they want to eat if anything
noodle bar was the expression of
you this is what I'm cooking
not exactly the classic definition of
hospitality but I felt that hospitality
needed a kick in the ass we were in
pursuit of a new kind of hospitality
that was meaningful to us and the diner
we happened to stumble upon it at sambar
at sambar my second restaurant I was
really trying to find my voice and plant
a fact from Momofuku that would
establish itself something other than a
one-hit wonder which Momofuku was this
meant I had to reach further work harder
risk more than I ever had at noodle bar
and I could not have failed bigger than
I did with this Asian burrito I'm not
going to put a photo up in the end it
was blessing in disguise it allowed me
to feel completely free in creating new
combinations of food flavors and
techniques a nothing to lose we were
liberated if we were going to go out of
business again we were going to do it in
style with that very real perspective of
losing everything including the shirt
off my back
following the culinary status quo the
traditions of what I should and
shouldn't do just didn't matter anymore
all our bad ideas started to seem like
good ideas and somewhere in that mess I
knew we could find something really
delicious
like most cooks and people who like good
food I like sea urchin I love sea urchin
I wanted to serve it at sambar but in a
different way than serve it raw or on
rice yet as you might see in a Japanese
restaurant those are very well
understood ways of eating it and I
thought cooking it would be an
abomination
cook Dooney you know you see it
sometimes in pasta or risotto but that's
not something I wanted to do either so I
started working on a dish
eventually I realized I could maintain
and highlight the purity of the sea
urchin by serving in a dangerously
contrasting environment
I cook black tapioca pearls like you'd
see in bubble tea in pineapple juice and
serve them in a bowl ripping hot way
hotter than anybody should ever eat I
had to deal with trying to get the best
sea urchin at the time because you know
purveyors don't want to sell a place
called Momofuku you know especially
really good Santa Barbara sea urchin and
I put that next to the tapioca we turn
tofu into a sort of like this whipped
cream very light and a cloud and put
that on the Uni there was furikake this
sort of Japanese rice seasoning
scallions yuzu Kosho for a citrusy spice
apple juice and for sweetness which is
also high in malic acid just sort of
opens up your palate it was a
full-throttle dish that should never
have worked and I would never have done
this dish in any other state of mind and
I wouldn't have made it if it just it
just made me feel like I needed a vomit
you know trying to serve something
really delicious and trying to vomit
because it was it was hot and cold it
was crunchy and soft you know sweet and
spicy but after dozens and dozens of
iterations you know the last one felt
like magic this dish was a catalyst for
the rebirth of sambar which launched
sambar from being this really failed
venture of an Asian burrito into
eventually a New York Times three-star
restaurant and we kept on pushing and
pushing pushing where we reached as
highest number 26 in the world and again
it's like that's something I found in
myself feeling I that nausea that that I
have to vomit is actually something I
found in every dish that has been really
instrumental in my life you know
you know I and that's sort of what I'm
trying to get to all of my chefs to do
right that's that's for me to understand
and not everybody wants to go down that
path because it's a hard road and I feel
like I'm growing when I push myself to
those limits emotionally and I get the
best out of myself but you know there's
some people that don't understand that
and they didn't understand that dish
critics liked it
chefs loved it but it's hard to explain
- younger cooks or new people how to
make a dish like that because you sort
of have to lose yourself all our
restaurants for the most part or open
kitchen you can see everything how they
eat and how they react and I can always
change few things to evoke a different
response a little more spicy a little
different knife cut on a vegetable liver
different texture didn't matter because
like I can sort of tailor it as we go
you know and I always try to go back to
that Looney dish because there are two
things at the same time and somewhere in
that dichotomy you know was a secret
path of new deliciousness again at that
time I did not know how to explain any
of this I still don't know if I do but
as we continue to grow I can no longer
be omnipresent at the restaurants each
restaurant is a collaboration between
myself and the chef's cooking is hard
enough
managing people for me is next to
impossible especially since I can't
dangle and attract the bonus stock
options in front of them as an incentive
I can only promise they will get better
at their craft learn better techniques
and be part of a winning team so I
learned to let go a little bit and give
chefs the tools to find the balance on
their own recently one of my head chefs
put this dish on the menu a beef tongue
sandwich on rye with bone marrow soup
and I can't remember what exactly
happened other than I saw it in service
and I lost my
and you know he loved the dish and it
just was the pickup was stupid it was
too long and for the fool for what went
in it there wasn't a return and you know
like most young dishes to a young Chefs
heart it plays upon something he grew up
eating but it was too over the top
it doesn't look complicated but there's
a lot of stuff going on there it's too
complicated it relied on nostalgia
instead of actual appeal talking about
its story adds up but just because a
dish makes sense doesn't mean it's going
to work and it just it definitely didn't
work you know you have the bone marrow
soup you have fried corn ershon's it's
just I still can't believe we served it
and and worst of all it was a safe move
for him he put nothing at stake it was
not reaching for high or low it was
reaching for the middle which I am
vehemently against he wasn't trying to
make people forget where they wore he
wasn't trying to transport them to that
sort of level of ecstasy that I want
he wasn't risking anything when I was
younger and didn't know any better I
would have thrown that dish across a
restaurant in a full crowded restaurant
in a fit of rage but this moment in time
in the restaurant I just chilled out and
I decided to let it play out
I told him to look at the sales I told
them more importantly look at the plates
coming back to the kitchen because that
tells you everything and I knew there
would be too many half-eaten dishes of
beef tongue and bone marrow soup
he wasn't cooking for the customer he
was making the dish for himself even
though it looked a little different you
could get those flavors at any Jewish
delicatessen and I wanted him take those
flavors to a whole new level or make it
the best version anyone had ever seen
and that's the mindset you have to have
I firmly believe that it was neither
ultimately he took it off on his own
accord I didn't have to humiliate him
and if I had demanded he removed the
dish it would have crushed him he
wouldn't have learned anything from that
experience and I would have lost one of
the most talented cooks I've ever hired
or had the pleasure of working with and
we worked and we
worked on it trying to get him to think
about flavors and textures and making
food that would evoke that response from
a customer and I wasn't looking for an
immediate return on this investment it's
it's not instant gratification and
that's hard for a chef because we get
into this business because we want
everything to be instant you know the
here and the now but I'm trying to see
both short and long term place long term
he's going to learn to better critique
his own dishes and this is a dish that
he came up next you know a few months
later and he's trying to build his
confidence and this is one of the best
dishes I've ever had and it's sort of a
same thing it's a sandwich so open-faced
sandwich there's texture from the
pickled hearts of palm on top there's
you know the sardines for a little bit
fat and holds on which will taste a
little bit later it's just a great great
dish very simple and very complicated so
you know I tried to make sure that we
teach failure and and trying to get
better at teaching failure we needed to
sort of systemize what we were doing so
in 2010 we launched our culinary lab and
we were in the pursuit of trying to find
anything we actually had no idea what
the hell was going on it was sort of in
vogue to have a lab at the time and and
it's hard to fail intentionally fail
when you have dinner service your
customers you have plumbing disasters
there's there's just the worst things
that can happen and then in the lab I
could create a structure where there was
sort of this go-for-broke mentality
every day where we could document it and
take the sort of scientific approach to
food that we had never done before you
know this freedom of failure led to the
creation of hosana and bond G you know
this project started considering
everyday items in our kitchen that we
didn't quite understand
Tatsuo bushi which is used to make
Japanese dashi soy sauce nice O's or
fundamental or fundamental in Japanese
ingredients but we didn't really know
how they were made and we didn't know if
we could make them in the East Village
that of Japan so I had the bright idea
that our goal was to make the best
versions of that in the world after
going to Japan many times and seeing how
they're making and I was like we can do
this you know we started to make soy
sauce and then we realized could we make
it with something else
hoo-wee could we swap it out for New
York State grains legumes and proteins
that are based locally as far as we know
this was the first time anyone tried to
substitute these ingredients we wanted
to pay homage to these classic Japanese
culinary staples but the same time we
want to destroy them because we felt we
could do it better and we're not there
yet but we're going to get there to us
replacing those traditions meant
steering away and creating our own after
all if you fundamentally understand
Japanese cuisine it's not about using
the real thing or something authentic
it's about what's using fresh and what's
close to you you know really paying
respect to the to our around you
the idea of importing these goods was
the antithesis of Japanese food to me so
in a way we started cooking real
Japanese food because we were making all
our own products the results were
astounding a holy moment
hopefully you'll taste that outside
these products did not fall into our
laps there were a lot of work over four
years of research and development and
you know currently using restaurants
around the country the lab was given the
freedom to fail fail big you know hope
really fail big and the space to refine
as they went the freedom to create this
type of structure to understand and to
evolve is the only way Momofuku my cooks
can evolve you know preserving that as
environment is our number one goal as a
chef you learn to salt to taste
everyone's cooked here everyone salted
something and you taste as you go and
you taste and you're just seasoning you
taste and adjust seasoning eventually it
becomes intuition no one is born with it
you learn from over seasoning and you
learn from under seasoning my role as a
chef now is to not provide the tools you
know to measure exactly how much salt
cuz there's some restaurants that
measure exactly to the milligram you
know I want to create that intuition
where people feel like they're in that
that structure and chaos and I think in
that dichotomy they're going to be able
to know what really great food is and
when new cooks ask me how much salt they
need to add to a dish
I tell them to over season and under
season at the same time I try to apply
that paradox to everything we do thank
you very much